potential scandal brewing for Ted Cruz
you're following this did you know about
this
good night that's me a new thing if they
don't know what I'm talking about
up top I just leave yeah and you and I
get in a car and we go and we get a
hamburger right right that'll show them
yeah but I keep up with these garbage
scandals yeah this is a big story for
Ted Cruz on Twitter last night someone
discovered that Republican senator Ted
Cruz had liked a tweet from a porn
account yeah yeah as you can imagine
that was one very embarrassing day for
that porn account
[Applause]
I'm working on my ted cruz does he have
that kind of thing going yeah yeah I
think he's actually holding his fingers
over his eyebrows most of the time
yeah Republican senator Ted Cruz is
blaming the porn tweet on a staffer
logging onto his account at 1:00 a.m.
that's what he said what happened yeah
by the way if my wife is watching honey
two nights ago at 2:00 a.m. I got up to
use the bathroom and hired a staffer
just today - eight just a day
[Laughter]
no I'm strict about these things you had
your chance you're like that didn't get
what it should we'll jump in with our
clappy class just a day and a half after
Hurricane Emma and did Disney World
managed to reopen today yeah yeah
Disney's biggest obstacle after the
storm was to get the robots from the
Hall of Presidents to stop looting that
was the problem the second time they had
to shoot McKinley and oh for god sake it
was a long time ago people acting like
they care no too soon
new $1000 iPhone coming out you excited
about that really you are now I know
where the rich people are sitting on
with the release of its new high-end
iPhone 10 Apple may soon become the
first US company to be worth one
trillion dollars yeah and that's just
from selling five new iPhone tens five
will get you there the new this is cool
the new iPhone will be able to track
stair climbing and mountain hiking yeah
so the big question is big question is
will it have any features for Americans
it has a shows watched feature yeah nine
malcolm in the middle' zai benched I
went back yeah I did
Pope Francis said that in his early 40s
he attended weekly appointments with a
Jewish therapist the Pope went to a
Jewish therapist yeah
Pope said he went to a Jewish therapist
so he could better understand his boss
so some were clapping just because they
saw others clapping they don't want to
be left out you know movie it's huge
success right a bunch of you have seen
it and we'll get to that this is weird
Professional Children's clowns
Professional Children's clowns are upset
that the Stephen King movie it makes
them look like murderers that's true
yeah and professional murderers upset
that it makes them look like children's
clowns that's the thing that's weird
[Applause]
we do a volume business in Britain in
Britain a man waved a knife and his
penis around it customers inside a
McDonald's yeah and guess what it was
still the healthiest thing ever seen
McKinley's McKinney stole a TV from a
Walmart come on
you